That's "peekaboo" in Japanese.
How are you?
This is my friend Jenna.
Jenna's always going on crazy adventures...
...and traveling places I wish I could go to.
Travel is so important.
It leaves you speechless,...
...then makes you a storyteller.
Wow, tell us a story.
I took a picture with a donkey in Puerto Vallarta.
So, what's your job?
Professional nomad.
Student of life.
I got that from your Instagram.
I think she means, what do you do that you can afford to travel so much?
How can you afford not to?
Travel is the one thing you buy that makes you richer.
Her dad invented YouTube.
Seriously, everyone should travel.
I don't think I can.
I have so many student loans.
I'm poor.
So was I, then I traveled.
My boss says I can have two days off every week for my weekend.
Where should I go?
You have to go to Bali.
Tickets are $1500 and 25 hours each way.
The world is a book, and those who do not travel read but a page.
You're right.
I booked it!